okay
so dan you know all uh very well because
he's been co-hosting this entire thing
we also have stoic dan who gave the
presentation
earlier leads five different meetup
groups
three of them are about stoicism right i
think
so he's got a lot of practical
experience and background he also
pops into a lot of other stoic groups as
well so you might think of him as a
a good person for best practices you
know he could talk about what works what
doesn't work
we have gabriel bl blot from the
minnesota stoix i understand that you
have several different co-organizers up
there uh so he is representing them
uh we have kevin smith from the des
moines stoix who's here for stoicon x
milwaukee
last year and then we have fred arzola
who actually i'm going to put on the
spot
to talk a little bit about the
transformation that
they carried out because as i understand
it you had
a face-to-face group and now it's a
purely
online group but it's supposed to be for
the entire midwest so why don't we
start with that and then i'll throw some
questions at you
and anybody in the audience who wants to
ask a question about organizing or
you know how to find people go ahead and
write your questions in the chat so go
ahead fred
sure so about three years ago i moved to
ohio a job brought me here in northwest
ohio
i'm a new york city guy and i was
introduced to stoicism
in san diego i was there for a year so
with the san diego stores
but when i came to ohio northwest ohio i
couldn't find a group
and so i decided to just start one
and we called it the northwest ohio
stoix to kind of show the geography
kind of the catchment area and then
um we went virtual because of covet 19
and greg lopez who spoke earlier sent
out a
call to people who wanted to
kind of more permanently start a
group and our group was uh
you know we were okay meeting virtually
and we decided to
be a permanent virtual group but then we
made
some changes right first you know as a
group we decided that was good
uh we changed the name to broaden the
catchment area to
more you know midwestern right so that
was that
and then we called it we call it the ver
the midwest
virtual stowa right so from the name
you get a sense that this is a little
bit more permanent
uh and what's been interesting about
that is we haven't
changed the way well we've had some
minor changes in the way we process
uh but it's broadened the area so we've
had a person from say washington dc
uh who joined us or broader parts of
ohio so it's been a it's been a it's
been a smooth transition and an
interesting transition
that's a good thing to open up for the
entire group then
since we all had to go online uh the
only stoic on x that isn't online is in
moscow
uh and i actually wrote them and said
are you sure you're not doing an online
event and i said
we're not but all of the rest of us are
so
the transition the pivot online how has
it been i the what you were talking
about with people coming in from
other places you know uh stoic dan is an
example he he comes to our milwaukee
stoic
fellowship it seems like we're
broadening the net
what is what is your experience been all
of you with that
i can jump in here the um
going online is just one of the ways
that i think a group
has to adapt to the times
you know through the years we went
through other adaptations
you know i tried to have a spanish
speaking group
and a portuguese speaking group for
stoicism and we had very limited
results so i as a stoic i realized this
is
my stoic chance i i gotta say that this
did not work i'm gonna try something
else
and with the pandemic going online has
been a change in the way that we prepare
the materials
that we post the events ahead of time
we've got to have a zoom link of course
in there
i found as a zoom organizer that you can
have
one link for every monday night group
or a different one for every friday
night group kind of keep them apart
that helps a little bit and uh oh and
also of course
we've seen benefits in going online
uh my orlando stoics group has attendees
from brazil
and nepal in tibet which is
astounding for me because i get to ask
them about their cultures once in a
while you know i'm not
i don't normally put people on the spot
but in this case i had to learn about
nepalese people and brazilians it was a
great opportunity
i would like to add that it's
sad because we we're such social
creatures and being in physical contact
is such a
drive for us and so there's definitely a
number of people that
dropped off once you started to go
online because
they there was that that want a need for
that social community
and you don't quite get that same
feeling once you are just
using your computer um and
but yeah just as stoic dan said uh the
the the breath of the people that you
can then actually bring
in and know you're no longer constrained
to your physical locality
is something great and um i don't know
if we're talking about
uh claudia the same person from brazil
um coming into these different ones um
but yeah
it's great to have this international
connection
gabriel and kevin have you had a lot of
people coming from outside of your
particular group to your online
uh meetups uh yes we
transitioned probably when most everyone
else did in late
march or early april and it was fairly
seamless
um at first i was most of our regulars
that we had in person
although that's slowly grown over time
like stoic dan comes to mind
several times and he's in orlando um
my family is all over the united states
so one of my brothers is really into
uh stoicism and in maryland so he got to
start attending
we have people from toronto all over
california texas et cetera
so that's certainly been a benefit um
we had a book club where uh for one of
donald robertson's books and he was
uh guest uh at the end when we finished
up and got to speak about the book
something we would have never been able
to do if we weren't online
because he was in greece at that time so
there's a lot more opportunities now
there is some of that personal
connection that's lost
when it's online only we used to
after meetups meet up to eat or drink
or whatever it is and there was a lot of
friendships formed
um where now it's just virtual so it's
not quite the same but it's
um there's a lot of we will continue
being virtual
long after this virus is done but we
will also probably have
in person as well but it's been a lot of
success
one of the things i wanted to ask about
was best practices
and worst practices things you tried
that
definitely nobody else should try or
um things that worked out particularly
well and yeah i'll
you know mention we talked about this a
little bit earlier
um so both stoic dan and dan hayes are
doing these stoic walk and talks that
seems like a particularly good practice
a little bit challenging up here in the
midwest
in the winter of course but there's
there's other places we were
experimenting i think with
the grand avenue as a possibility for
before they close down for
for walking this is the mall yeah and
so so what are some other best practices
things you think really worked out or
some things that you're like man that
did not
that did not work at all
hey greg it's andy i can jump in with
something here
if that's right um and just so everyone
knows i'm right downstairs from greg and
we're sharing bandwidth so you'll see my
my photo not my video just to make sure
we both stay connected
um but one of the things that i would
suggest to anyone who's looking to
organize a stoic meetup or
um you know obviously we're virtual
right now but depending on your location
you may have some
capacity to engage with others in a
physical space and um that would be just
you know to remember the public spaces
that are hungry
for folks to join
and you know be there right now so we
typically used libraries
at the beginning because our libraries
and our municipality are free of
charge so we could use the meeting rooms
for free and that was always helpful
but you know just in terms of kind of
pursuing the good
i would say that if there's a cafe or a
restaurant
perhaps there's a capacity limit but if
you are looking to do something in
person
to remember to reach out for community
partnerships
that can always be like a good good
right like a mutually beneficial
arrangement so that might be something
to consider depending on where you're
located
if you're trying to keep you know
virtual events as your sort of primary
connection as we are right now obviously
zoom is great and
you know that's what we're using today
eventbrite um
certainly meetup is what we use for
stoic fellowship but
not to forget your radio stations and
community calendars and other things to
solicit interest
we talked to an editor recently of a
local paper and because there's so
few things happening the people who are
publicizing events and trying to get you
know folks
engaged in things within the community
are always happy to celebrate or
publicize or let people know that you've
got a meet-up coming up
um and so where it used to be harder to
get press right now those same press
folks are hungry for the opportunity to
share good news about people connecting
so that's what i would add to this
conversation for right now
if i can add to that i agree with andy
um
so in in northwest ohio
we decided to meet on a sunday morning
so as you can imagine that's a very
heavily church going time and
and a lot of places are closed um
and so we uh started meeting at a
unitarian universalist church
who found the group kind of symbolic or
right kind of uh
in that sense and so we were able to
meet there on sunday mornings
and so that that really worked out well
the other thing is what we do that's
helpful for us
in trying to maintain a sense of
community and i'm not sure if it's
unique to us but
after we we start and we share
announcements for the good of the group
is we always begin with a five-minute
journaling um
usually i begin with a a quote from a
stoic a classic
uh piece or maybe a reflection from a
contemporary writer
or a virtue like sometimes i'll begin
you know in the past week how did you
live out your virtues
or if we do seneca's you know what bad
habit did we did i put right in the past
week i usually
reflect on the past week and and then i
time it for five minutes
and we just write silently and then we
share and that seems to instead of
us jumping into the kind of intellectual
dialogue of stoicism
it it creates a sense of reflection
kind of community in that sense
so that's one thing that we do with our
group
another good tip that i found uh through
the years
is when you see newcomers in the meeting
remember as the host to
reiterate the rules of the meeting for
example you know my
one big rule is we don't we don't talk
politics
because that divides people and i've
seen people leave the group when it gets
political
but another interesting rule that i
found over the years
is uh in the tampa stoics group when we
used to meet in person
one of the members her name is mary she
would often say to newcomers
you can criticize dan he likes it you
know
or if you have your own interpretation
please say it
because if i said that you wouldn't have
as much gravity as her saying it
and so i never planned for that to
happen but it was a very good outcome
i i would like to echo stoke stan uh not
allowing politics
we definitely do not allow that in our
group um at all we want it to be as well
welcoming as possible um i would say
mainly variety
uh just variety we have variety in
topics uh
facilitators the times we offer things
the days of the week uh the when we were
in person the location
uh we're in the twin cities so we had
some in st paul some in minneapolis
in the northern part southern parts to
enable people that might not have been
able to go
because of work life whatever it might
be
so always having a lot of options there
um definitely helps
one thing that also helped is uh stoic
dance certainly knows it uh
there and i'm sure many on here know it
there's a lot of overlap between
stoicism
and buddhism so we wound up doing some
collaboration with another local
buddhist group
and that really cross-promoted both of
them within
and there was a lot of interest in those
so i would all
especially if you're new i would
definitely cross promote
with an existing larger group and it can
help them get off the
off the ground there i i'd like to add
because we're wandered into the question
of religion
is i also try to not make that divisive
an issue at all like you know i look at
it as like if you are non-religious
that's perfectly fine it's a good
philosophy of life
if you are religious this is um for the
vast majority of religions
is something that can easily be laid on
top of these things and it does not have
to be
in direct conflict with these things
and uh you just mentioned the buddhism
overlaps
and we found incidentally because the
minimalist group happened to meet just
before
our group so
we found they had some overlap too
though they we didn't stick together
very long
but for a while there we would attend
their meetings and they would attend
ours
those few of us so i that might be
another group look
at what you know combining
stoic dan knows about that
that sounds like a a great idea we've
got a uh some
conversation here that i let's let's
jump into it so sean said any thoughts
about how stoicism can be combined with
art
in a zoom group drawing together with my
creative friends makes for some really
good connection i can't think of how to
mix
stoic with art but the mingling of mine
and heart would be powerful
and then andy weighed in and said
journaling couldn't could be applied to
art sketching
painting and claudia said a good art
here i think would be storytelling about
lives and culture of the stoics
being studied and then timothy weighed
in said we've done stoicism through art
history images
so it sounds like there's actually a lot
of room for incorporating what's called
the visual
aspect with with zoom what are what are
your thoughts about that
yeah timothy there is one of our
facilitators here
and he's a retired art teacher um and
yeah he taught one on art so
unfortunately i wasn't there so i don't
have as many details of that particular
meetup
but we've certainly incorporated that
mindfulness
uh walking other things that aren't
necessarily
like considered super stoic where we've
had other ones on judgments
or virtue and the more traditional
topics so
it's good to see how it relates to other
aspects in life and again that's
sort of a cross promote you got a lot of
people that also like art
and that might be interested in stoicism
and how do they relate because
they do it's just not always super
explicit
it's probably self-evident but what i
neglected to say is
after the journaling we spend time
sharing
uh our experiences and that becomes very
rich right that's where people share uh
how they've lived out uh the stoic
virtues
in their life so i think yeah i think
that that applied that could apply to
art
and that that's a wonderful way to
implement that
um and you know again the idea of
doing it but also processing it as a
group
i'll just mention i put something in the
chat um on
sunday the first of november there's
another stoic on x focused on journaling
and i'll actually be presenting at that
but i would welcome anyone who's
interested in talking about that a
little bit more to sign up
um the bitly link is in the chat
i like i like the idea of of the
journaling
suggestion at the beginning of a meeting
another thing the orlando stoics did for
a while is we had
uh social time after the meeting that is
for those who could stay an extra 15
minutes
i would just have no agenda and everyone
could talk about whatever they want
although they did often gravitate to
star trek references at that point
so i joke that we're no longer orlando
stoics now we're orlando star trek
but um but it did build community it was
good
make it so so that's actually a good
lead in
um since we are forced into this online
space it's a little bit
harder to do some of that that stuff i
mean we can have sort of an unprogrammed
talk afterwards um
but yeah i mean i've been thinking about
that too with this this this stoic on
you know we could do breakout rooms but
those aren't quite the same thing as
meeting somebody out in the hallway and
and chatting with them and then catching
up with them how do we
uh how do we do that sort of thing in
this online setting that we're probably
going to
remain in for for quite a while i'll
speak to that quickly um and it's also
kind of a comment on what john smiley
put in the
chat about q a lecture getting people to
read resources
i'm one of the few people that i know
and have talked to that loves this
shift online in the pivot and i think
it's great that we can all
you know connect virtually i think tech
can be a huge enhancement an enabler for
connection especially for people who are
less likely
to maybe speak up or join in if they
have to physically be present with
someone i think we're reaching a
completely different audience in
completely different ways
so i'm a big fan of this i'm not saying
i'm a big fan of the restrictions or
covet or anything like that don't get me
wrong but the idea that we can
interact with people across the world
and share ideas i think is a cause for
celebration
and so i think the big thing is from my
mind and the events that i've hosted and
in the workshops that i've done on this
very topic
is to acknowledge that it's different
but not focus on what we cannot do and
instead focus on what we can do
so getting people to interact with the
technology can be intimidating at first
if you start with just a micro lesson on
having people throw up an emoji
or change their name or do something so
that they feel a little bit more
tech competent i think it can help a lot
starting every event by having people
put you know just a word
in the chat that describes how they're
feeling right now or a question that
they have
or you know something like that can just
get that flow going
and then the one is no longer one
they're one of many
not to you know go back to star trek
references but
um i think that there's incredible
opportunity there for
us to just really connect more and
breakout rooms can be great
especially if you don't try to control
them right if you manage your
expectations and you don't try to overly
structure them
and you say here's some possible prompts
i think what happens is folks emerge
as being much more comfortable than
we're thinking they are
and the less we talk about how different
it is in a negative way
and the more that we focus on how
different it is in a way that it's just
simply different
um it gives us more freedom to connect
as people via the technology rather than
feeling like we're forced into this new
way of being
because you're right we don't know how
long this is going to you know
go on for but let's make the most of it
right now
all of us together you know are in this
room in this space
um some perhaps in pajamas some perhaps
in the morning some perhaps at night
we have our you know food and beverages
of choice we can take a break and leave
and no one is the wiser
it's actually much more comfortable in
many ways to interact and get what you
want out of participation rather than
feel that you've got this like
you know framework and you have to be
present and you know you can't just take
a moment to pause journal reflect on
what you're hearing
um you know there's there's lots of
advantages so i would just say that's
one of my big things is to kind of focus
on what we can do
um and really enjoy it
there were two points that andy said
that uh i want to just kind of punctuate
one thing made me laugh
is we have a handful of rules also like
stoic dance says and one is
we will be temperate in our discussion
right no monopolizing
of the group because you know stoic folk
could talk
and uh but the other thing that's
interesting is i'm in a different group
i'm also in a in a writing group
and we have members in the writing group
uh who have joined
the group and
you know the idea of of the writing
group going back
meeting in the coffee shop is you lose
you're just going to lose those people
because some people they're just from
different states
and so there's also there's now it's
curious the longer we're in this moment
and these some of these groups uh really
you know strengthen and build these
relationships
returning back it's going to be hard i
think for
certain folks who have to look for other
groups closer to them
well this is this is a good uh sort of
lead-in to some of the questions that
people have been
asking so john smiley was asking about
duties that we have to members we'll
come back to that but i want to pick on
this one in particular because we've got
brian saying online meetings are my only
hope to converse with others in english
a godsend for me
mark smith saying online has been very
empowering for marginalized people that
can't or are uncomfortable with public
engagement
and then kirsten says i'm shy more
likely to attend a virtual meeting as
opposed to convincing myself to drive to
unknown
locations so if if we do transition
back to face to face do we have a duty
do you think to maintain an online
alternative an online presence
maybe we maybe we should think about
coordinating that you know
so mad venettas like little catchphrases
you know bad fortune born nobly is good
fortune i feel like
this whole pandemic is our bad fortune
but
born nobly we have now found new ways of
conversing and interacting
that have benefits that we would not
have known be
without this particular situation and
i think that just because we will
potentially uh or
eventually we'll get over this pandemic
um
that does not mean that we have not
realized that these things are
beneficial
and these will still continue to
maintain themselves
in some form or another maybe diminish
but i believe they'll will stay
i agree i think the door's been opened
and we'd be fools to close it in many
ways but i think it's
you raise a good question greg and that
is how do we effectively
structure this then right do we have a
monthly virtual and a monthly
in person and one of the groups that i
belong to is doing just that
you know they're at a point where they
can bring people in the space is large
enough they've got plenty of room for
social distancing
and they're having conversations on uh
you know diversity equity and inclusion
and they run a virtual session in a
in-person session so that people can
feel very comfortable to
dip in or dip out as they wish and i
think that you know
i think we should uh actually do that
especially for groups like this where
the sharing and the connection i mean i
just think of stoicon
last weekend and how many people were
saying this was amazing like i never
could have traveled i never could have
afforded just the travel
and here i was able to just donate my
dollar and have a full day of enrichment
thank you so much and you know there are
more than a handful of those comments i
think it's important to note
and actually this is something i was
recently kind of considering i was
thinking
once this is over i haven't got this
thought out or i have
no conclusion yet but there's
probably a way to do both in in-person
meetings
and a virtual meeting at the same time
i'm just thinking maybe like
some of us have conference rooms at our
offices if it you know if you're built
if your office would allow it
or you could do the video conferencing
online while you were meeting
in person with the local people it's
just a thought i've kind of had in the
back of my head
that would that what they call an
educational hybrid
meeting right so some people are there
face to face and then it's being
broadcast to others
the interesting thing that's happened
with the orlando and tampa stoix group
is the tampa group was ready to get back
to meet in person
before the orlando group and what
naturally
worked out i i didn't plan for any of
this but the tampa group
a new one of the regulars stepped up to
be the host
so now he's hosting the group on friday
nights
and i mentioned in an email to all the
tampa stoix members
if you want to continue with the online
meeting come to orlando stoix
which is all online so it naturally now
we have in-person
and virtual meetings at the same time
but different hosts and different topics
so it just worked its way out by itself
yeah i know we're definitely going to
have online classes
well after meetups well after this is
over
i'd probably do a little bit of both but
the online
offers a lot of advantages one for
people out of the area or from small
rural areas that there
is no club that they could go to um as
well as people that
might be just too shy that they they
would feel really uncomfortable going
into an established group that everyone
knows one another
where zoom really opens it up they don't
have to have their camera on they don't
even have to talk
we have plenty of people that just come
to listen and they say that right at the
beginning and that's fine
um they they just want to do that so
and like even one of our very regular
members is moving tomorrow to georgia
but he'll be able to maintain uh keep
coming to our recruit now that we're
virtual
where if we weren't virtual uh that
would be the end of our
that would be the end of visiting the
minnesota stoix he's gonna have to go
find one in atlanta at that point
so i think there's a lot of advantages
and i know we plan on
remaining online but we would probably
have some in persons
uh after that fact so still
dan brought up a a topic about having
others start uh
doing meetings and i think this is one
thing to really maintain a good
community is giving
agency to your community members to
uh give them small jobs and once you
give them some part of that it
makes them feel like it is their own and
it makes them want to come back more
as well as you know good leadership is
also proper delegation
yeah i think that that that's that leads
to another
important issue so you know a lot of
these stoic groups have been around for
maybe
uh five years tops and this is also
something that we're dealing with with
the modern stoicism
organization succession planning right
you don't want to have the same people
running everything
all the time right you want to start
getting people who can
organize and and take over and
you know like for example with the mo
you know mke stoics i don't plan on
on being one of the main organizers for
for the next 20 years
um i want to see some other people
developed who can
who can jump in there as well i think
that makes groups much more
healthy and it sounds like the minnesota
stoics have really been
you know training up quite a quite a few
people
maybe you want to say something about
that gabriel because i you know when i
first contacted you i think
i was i was contacting uh nick who's now
moved on right
so he kind of passed the baton so to
speak but a whole bunch of batons
uh yeah it's been passed several times
uh
so it's really we keep grooming them
from
existing members after they've been
there
long enough i know tim is here
who's now a co-facilitator started
expressing interest
so the first couple we collabed and then
uh when he was comfortable on his own he
started doing his own
um i started we used to only meet once a
month
um and there was an interest in a more
frequent meeting
but the hosts at that time once a month
was all they could do
so i asked and so i started up as well
and so now we're up to like five or
eight meetups uh
a month where we were just at one only i
don't know two and a half three years
ago
so it's really reaching out to existing
members that
clearly have the passion and knowledge
to do it and
um trying to groom them or sometimes
they're come to me but other times
or they have a suggestion for meetup and
like well why don't you do that and so
we have
yet another host starting up next month
on it's more of like a recap an end of
the
week recap of like where did stoic
principles work for you and
um like what situations and then also
like you could ask for help for others
because there's so many times people ask
for like practical advice okay we got
all the theory down because
i'm notorious i'll do two hour lectures
on theory
but it's like how do we actually do this
um how does it actually make our life
better and people love those personal
stories um
and this one will literally be just that
so
you know gabrielle made some really good
points uh first
again moving from an urban center to a
rural area
the benefit of the online meeting is
just
huge when it's so limited in in certain
areas
also as was mentioned we have members
who come on and they don't turn on the
video
you know they but they participate fully
you know they they give their
their their input um or they're just
listening but they just
keep the the video off and and that's
okay but they're
regular they're regular members you
couldn't do that
in a regular meeting and you know a
final
thought is one of the benefits of of the
the virtual especially when we went to
the midwest uh
virtustowa is we we had new members who
were more veteran stoics right people
more along the way
and that really added a richness
and a depth to the group and insight uh
because when when i started you know we
had more novices
more neophytes there including myself so
that's really
been a wonderful benefit just being
up virtually i think one other thing
that's really cool about the
conversation that we're having
um and going back i think to what
gabrielle was just saying
the um and i think fred you echoed this
but the ability to actually do some
practical application
in these groups is wonderful and i think
that you know at soicon we saw a lot of
people talking about principles and
practices of stoicism as applied to
dealing with the pandemic or dealing
with pain or dealing with relationships
when we first started the stoic
fellowship it was such a curious group
that showed up and
it was kind of like some people had a
background some people didn't
but what we invariably seemed to do in
the very early stages
was talk about how this was impacting
our work our lives things like that and
one thing that i've always thought would
be really cool and maybe virtual means
would allow that
is to have kind of a collection of you
know short submissions where people who
are really curious about
how if they're in healthcare for example
how are other people doing this
um could be used and there could be
almost you know kind of an
inter-fellowship um space to share some
of the journaling practices share some
of the stories
have a meet-up maybe where it's fred's
group plus you know the midwest group
plus
whatever and do what we're doing here
today in the stoicon x
our stoicon milwaukee last year was
amazing it was great fun
fire alarm and all you know we broke
bread together we had
all kinds of fantastic conversations but
there was something really great about
being able to connect all of us
in this space and i think perhaps this
should be something that we continue to
do i know
you know we have an international
presence here today i mean it would be
great to continue to have more of these
um kind of larger group meetings not
just
stoicon x but you know to have more of
these conversations for the same reasons
and not to do i mean the stoic
fellowship does do some of that stuff
but it's like committees and
how to promote this and it's all a lot
of work
not as much fun so i think i think you
know
we need some good fun meetings or uh
variety meetings or something like that
there's a a
good question or a point here by by
trina
um for those who may be intimidated by
exploring stoicism
online is a great way to find out more
have you noticed an increase in women
and other changes to diversify your
groups and then
mark had a similar point about south
africa
how would you go about making stoic
events more accessible to
underprivileged
communities is there a duty to do that
should there be some sort of
stoic outreach so those are
those are some important points i think
what what do the rest of you think about
that
what i've found over the years is that
men
tend to attend meetings more than women
there's maybe something about stoicism
that appeals more
uh to men so therefore when women do
show up
or other uh smaller groups like also you
know i appreciate
uh when a person who's uh hindu or
muslim shows up
and the way that i encourage them in the
future is i just send them a little note
afterwards saying thank you for coming
thank you for adding to the conversation
just a little bit of that from the host
can encourage them to come more often
sometimes the topic we'll do it as well
yeah women in the group is always a
tricky topic
uh when we were in person i was
definitely dominated by males
but we do have more women online now not
more than 50
um but i the topics can make a
difference some of our most popular ones
were
on mindfulness and buddhism as well as i
recently had one on the softer side of
stoicism
emphasizing that kindness and gentleness
and patience and other pieces that are
not as emphasized as much it's usually
seen as cold or not caring about other
things or being immune to
troubles so those there's some topics
that might speak
uh to others better so just making sure
you have that variety and emphasizing
that
also that diversity in stoic thought
because it certainly existed there right
from the get-go
certainly aristos and others were
disagreeing right away
so it's okay to have that um so
as for underprivileged communities
that's a great question
i i don't have any insight there and
i'll be curious from the other panelists
you know we're a young group we're just
here we just started a year so it's
still pretty small but
in terms of gender it's about 50 50 um
and we've we've you know we've
basically just done studies of works uh
you know
uh we did epictetus and cheridian and
real marcus released meditations
now we're looking through you know
william irvine's a guide to the good
life
uh so
but the participation from a gender
perspective has been really
really good but what we are lacking is
this equity gap right people of color
um and you know i'm i'm hispanic uh
but you know i live in an area that's
predominantly homogeneous
so um
i'm just that that's an area i'm just
wrecking just acknowledging that that's
an
area that we don't have much diversity
in our group
and it's something that you know it's
important to address
i'd say it's gonna take a little bit of
marketing because we're all
fighting against this you know stiff
upper lip stoicism that
has been kind of like the pervasive
prevailing idea of what
it is to be a stoic and and this idea of
like putting out
as gabriel said of putting out topics
that
are much more enticing on that kind of
push back against that incorrect thought
with a little less stoicism
is a good way to start
i think people are hungry for connection
right now as well and i think that
you know the types of contemplative
lives that
people who are in a position of some pro
privilege have been able to live working
from home for example doesn't apply to
everybody right there's plenty of people
within the workforce that cannot make
that choice
um and i think that you know if you're i
agree with everyone about the
inclusivity piece if the goal is to
create more um a group that represents
the population of the community it
serves i guess right would be maybe the
best way to think about it is to make
sure that the messaging is reaching
everyone and
every single time we host an event greg
and i the last line is all are welcome
and we mean that
right it doesn't matter if you disagree
it doesn't matter if you
you know are here to fight us
on every topic and you know you come to
be the antagonist you're welcome in the
conversation and so i think
that's that's an important piece is
really making sure that as everyone has
said the
group dynamic the messaging the
reception you know the outreach all of
that is important
because it benefits us all and we learn
from one another through that type of
engagement
you know i think too in a city like
milwaukee which is
you know the most segregated large city
in the united states
um at least by some measures we probably
need to think
a little bit more once we start going
back to face to face about locations
because
when we you know when we're doing stuff
in shorewood
um that's that's a tough sell i think
for a lot of people
in some respect you know we do milwaukee
sofia which is the society of
philosophers in america on the south
side of milwaukee
uh in one of the other libraries and um
that's more you might say of a neutral
location
um so i think we're probably gonna have
to rethink
where we're meeting face-to-face for the
the
milwaukee stoic fellowship once we
resume
can i ask a question to fred really
quick
um you were talking about people that uh
kind of sit in your meetings without
having
their video on um how do you
make sure that these people aren't i
guess nefarious
um do you like vet them first and then
let them go
um no they've i mean
we you know they participate fully they
do the homework
they read they so uh they're
i mean unless there's some you know
conspiracy uh
they're they're fully participating like
in every way
i have been i haven't gotten a sense of
anyone doing anything
um if they were a sweeper they're really
putting in a lot of work to
to ruin a group
i'm not talking about the long-term ones
but like a new person if a new person
comes in and they don't want to talk and
they don't have their video off
is do you deal with them differently so
it we're so new right so i haven't had
to deal with that but i think that's a
good point right um i think to to be
why to use wisdom um and to you know and
and be discerning of that
and and just kind of and i think that's
part of the role of the facilitator of
the leader right to
to kind of see how that's being um you
know
how you're experiencing that so that's a
fair point though thank you
i think it's important too though to
remember that everybody's comfort level
in an online environment
is not the same i think someone who's
there for ill will will probably show
themselves pretty quickly
but we talk about this all the time and
you know sort of the pivot to online
education and there's a lot of faculty
at one of the schools that greg and i
both teach at who sort of have this
position that people should be present
and visible
and we have no idea what a home
situation is we don't know what kind of
bandwidth sharing needs to happen i mean
i'm not visible now because greg and i
would crash this zoom if we were both
trying to be on video
um but you know i've also been in in
meetings where
a person is participating to the
capacity that they're able because of
whatever is going on in the background
whatever is happening you know in their
economic situation
their domestic situation so i think it's
important just to treat
this as a neutral space and assume the
best unless someone shows you otherwise
because we don't know what we could be
you know sort of damaging um in terms of
that connection if we were to just
immediately sort of shuttle people out
or put them on the spot and ask them
questions i think that's a dangerous
pathway
so my two cents
i agree with andy and fred that there
are a couple members in our group in
orlando
who are calling in on their phone i
think it's either they don't have
webcams
or it's maybe a very old pc but
in general i tell newcomers if their
screen is blanked out
i just tell them you know you can hear
you can be here and you can listen and
when you feel comfortable with joining
the conversation
that's up to you because i do want to be
welcoming
um yeah i don't think people are i think
we need to be tolerant for those blank
screens
yeah we've had plenty of people that
come in and you have
zero participation since being online
but they they're obviously still coming
and enjoying it and they're not we
haven't had any rabble rousers luckily
um but we always encourage participation
uh but they can have as much or as
little as they would like so i'm not
calling them out or anything uh but i've
gotten plenty of comments after
oh i had a really good time in a like a
dm or a pm
afterwards so some people just
don't want to participate they want to
listen or they feel they don't know
enough about the topic and they might
appear stupid or
um or they're disturbing the group
dynamic because they clearly can tell a
lot of us know one another and have a
banter going so they just feel like the
odd person out or
i don't know what their situation is uh
so
but yeah that's fine if they don't
participate we don't
require it in any way
i think those are all really great
points
let's if you don't if all of you don't
mind going a little bit over time
let's grab
one more that came up a little bit
earlier
about uh duties i'm scrolling through it
um yeah first of this is from john
smiley
so he says we have a small core small
core group with the rest quite transient
our core group decided we'll meet in
person and outdoors through the winter
great way to practice discomfort but i
know the vast majority of members
won't want to do that i imagine in part
because of you know the weather and also
because of
concerns about covid so so what what
duties
do we as organizers have to
our our members obviously continuity
maintaining
you know meetings and things like that
but what else do we need to do
in your view going going beyond that
internal workings at orlando stoics is
uh
i don't often share this with others but
one of our members
keeps coming back because he likes
connecting things to chinese philosophy
so in each meeting as i'm preparing for
it if i can just connect one idea to
chinese philosophy
i know he's going to be a really happy
attendee
there's also another member briefly she
always calls in on her phone she cannot
see the screen
that i'm sharing so but she is reading
the article that i told everyone to read
in the first place
so i always pick one quote that i know
she can find easily in the article and
then i ask her to read it
because i know she doesn't have to see
my screen to do it
those are just little things it's like
it's like building a family you have to
pay attention to everyone
yeah so it's like extending inclusivity
through personal interactions yeah
that makes a lot of sense any any other
ideas
unrelated to that but about duties i
consider it as a
a host a duty to be very well informed
on the topic because i feel people are
coming for
authentic information so like
most of mine i'll spend around 20 hours
researching the topic
making sure it's well cited multiple
sources
so it's not just my opinion about it but
at the same time recognizing
when people don't agree with it that
that's fine
i'm simply pushing putting forward the
stoic position
on something it's not like it's
infallible and always
right on things but i think it's really
important that people have the proper
idea and so to me a duty is to make sure
i
have my material well known
and i'm staying informed about it
you know for me i try to be a resource
uh but also
um i'll purchase the kindle version of
something that were
studying and i'll just have it open
in case because sometimes we read
through pieces
and if someone can't buy the book can't
afford the book
you know i could just put it on the
screen and i could just say all right
today we're going to
just read it and it's just there so no
one is really
embarrassed about that
that's a great idea yeah i think that's
a good point the
accessibility issue and to minimize the
feeling of
you know this sort of like barrier right
like there's this elite knowledge and
only those who have it should come and
all of that i know
greg has done a great job with posting
reputable
you know to the earlier point but
reputable internet resources so that
someone can download it we've talked to
the libraries about having things set
aside
but just to create a culture of
knowledge sharing and the idea that
we're all here to learn and there may be
someone who is the expert
in our group but we can all learn from
one another
and i love that idea fred you know
yeah in terms of i always try to make
sure that i have
um when we do our readings that i
reference
uh either a free usually on the
on the internet option or very cheap
you know dollar or so and there are some
cases where i just bought
you know six copies and showed up with
them in case somebody needed them
found that helps
yeah there are definitely some books
that you can pay a lot of money for
among the stoic literature so we'd want
to avoid those
those particular editions
well we're a little bit over time
so any last thoughts that any of you
want to
weigh in with for this this great panel
so there's a project that greg
lopez has been doing as a mentorship
program
and where he's looking for stoic
leaders to help new stoic leaders and so
i'm mentoring
a gentleman down in the south um
by the name of adam and i would highly
recommend that all of you
go out there to help those new members
contact greg lopez for that
yeah that sounds like an excellent idea
similar to that the stoic fellowship has
the
new program called pairing or sister
program
where two groups work together and just
learn from each other
so i think uh pete flagella is the
main contact on if you want to get
paired up with another group
nothing to add just thank you very much
for the invitation
yeah i had a lot of fun and i look
forward to uh
joining the other groups of the hosts
here
i wasn't aware of some of these other
groups and uh
greg i've read so much of your work on
uh academia.edu and watched your videos
over the years so it's
funny to see you in person here well
sort of in person
virtual person yeah live so it was uh
i'm geeking out a little but anyway i
had a lot of fun thank you
yeah well thanks to all of you for
joining in on this panel i
am glad that you could come share your
expertise with
people we're going to upload this as a
video so it's going to have a much wider
outreach than just the people who are
able to be here
i think it'll be quite helpful thanks to
all the other speakers
some of whom are not here because
they're in other time zones that kind of
make it pretty late at this point in
time uh
but i think this is a pretty successful
event despite a few
technical uh difficulties mostly on my
end
so i'm going to bring it to
a close and say thanks to everybody
and i think that's that's pretty much
pretty much it thanks everyone
enjoy the rest of your weekend take care
you